hello unless this guy and I'm a
dominatrix we are here in in your in
your dungeon with these lovely tied
people what was this called they
basically human furniture at this point
what else would you offer just the
standard stuff tying up pain body
worship golden showers watersports
flogging slapping corporal punishments
yeah I had a question about safe words
what are the best ones Miami Beach
plunge
that's a good one I've also heard of
vomit and lawsuit my favorite safe words
are actually traffic lots a submissive
says either green and all red or yellow
if the person's name is Amber which
happened to me once Gray's oh my god yes
keep going and I'm ready to stop
everything in cuddle there me as the
dominant can say intersection which is
me checking in there because a gamba
that means oh actually no maybe leaves
up a bit because you know my biggest
kink is enthusiastic consent I'm a
massive sadist but only when they really
really love it I challenge you to rap
about latex heteronormativity and the
word Chop latex heteronormativity and
the word xiang lettuce yo in here lots
of love wanna guess let him pull tight
like a glove and a glove there you must
respect because this glove contains
latex lots of things have it arm may be
non sheepskin condom because other ones
made of animal flesh would not work with
the latex latex
oh yes yes y'all I want to get gloves
that a surgical I want to get different
colors like blue white and black when
you put them off you hear them swak look
like George Clooney in ER pull his latex
gloves up so far like eat Randa
inseminate a cow
I'd be like George calm down now need to
really stop it before the cow stamps
comes over and gives you a chomp on your
hand and starts to plumbing it goes
right down into one of four stomachs to
the cecum that's the appendix put it is
the end yes
that's the appendix and I append this
rap with one thing let me talk about I
hear the bell ring when you born a girl
boy your baby everybody like go naming
crazy they be like you've got the
ability to move against
heteronormativity you don't need to say
nomenclature will define and I'm not
sure whether it's easy to run and make
sense but I keep going keep up the
pretense keep flowing and show and I
ain't got the ability I keep going with
a heteronormativity it's like saying
that girl can't play games and boys
can't have pink in their names it's like
what why would you assign to that it's
not fun I don't align myself to that and
anyway let's end this from above bring
it down laters heteronormativity in
gloves there you go jumping up and down
saying yes is enthusiastic consent that
was okay good